The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Let me quick
do a wrap-up of where we are,
just so you remember
our context.
Class one was really
all about growth.
Economics, as you
all know, when we
talked about the contributions
that Solow and Romer made,
and they really forced us to
look at what we could call
two direct innovation factors.
What Solow called
technological-related
innovation we can
sort of translate that
as R&D. And Romer, the talent
base human capital engagement
research was his key term.
We read Dale Jorgensen,
and Jorgensen showed us
that technology-based
innovation really
was the driving causative
factor in the great growth
spurt of the 1990s.
That was the innovation wave
around the IT revolution,
as you remember.
And we talked about how there
were direct innovation factors.
So Romer contributed those,
arguably, and others.
But there are also
many indirect factors.
All right?
So less critical
factors, but this
is a complex ecosystem
of innovation.
Richard Nelson gives us a third
innovation factor, looking
at innovation as a system and
the organizational elements
within it and the connectedness
of the different actors
and the strength of
the different actors,
so that gives us a systems'
way of evaluating an innovation
system, whether it's national
or regional or local.
Nelson gives us a perspective
on how to look at that system.
Atkinson and others contributed
on innovation wave theory.
The way in which
economies grow is
that they bring these new
innovation waves on and scale
them up over an
extended period of time.
They start very gradually,
finally reach a point
where they can scale quickly.
There's always a bust, then
they scale more gradually.
That's kind of the stages
we've talked about.
We're now with
the IT revolution.
Charles Schulz
taught us to kind of
be aware of industrial policy.
And we talked a lot about
the government role here,
but that's a cautionary tale
of some problematic aspects
of a governmental role.
Classes 3 and 4 were really
about advanced manufacturing,
which we did as our
first big case study.
Obviously we'll have another
big case study today.
We had health last week.
Class 5 was on
innovation organization,
and we talked about
the different models
that kind of govern the ideology
of innovation in this country.
The associationalist
model, which
we could call the public-private
partnership kind of model.
The conservative model, which
is governmental intervention.
Government should stay
away from intervention,
including into the
innovation system
except at the most
basic kind of levels
versus a national security model
which justifies intervention
at any stage if the need is
related to national security.
And these debates go on.
There's a couple
of other models,
but those are the
ones that really
represent the core
debates that still go on.
We talked about the importance
of looking at innovation
from both the institutional
and the personal level.
So people innovate,
institutions don't.
You need to understand how
the institutions interact.
But in the end, people
own particular innovations
and bring them about.
So you've got to
understand innovation
at that personal level, as well.
We talked about Donald
Stokes and a core issue
in the US system, its
disconnected model.
The fact that we tend to
focus on early stage research
and have less focus
on the implementation
stages further along.
And that creates a significant
tech transition problem
in the US system.
Class 6 was about that how
to get across this, quote,
"Valley of Death," which
has been the major policy
preoccupation of US
science and technology
policy for the
last say 25 years.
And in contrast we read
Vernon Ruttan, another growth
economist, who taught
us that, by the way,
there's a whole parallel
system out there,
there's a parallel universe
in the way in which the US R&D
systems are organized.
There's a highly connected
defense information system
that's very different than
the somewhat disconnected
civilian side R&D system.
Class 7 was great group theory,
what does innovation look
like at the face to face level?
Innovation, again, is people,
it's not institutions.
And what are the
rules sets that tend
to govern the way in which
teams and groups of people
working on complex innovations.
How they come together?
How do they assemble?
How do they organize?
What are their rules?
So that's all about a
third direct innovation
factor, innovation organization,
at both face to face
and institutional levels.
Class 8 was around DARPA
as a very different kind
of model that attempts to
do both a connected model
and innovation through
a connected model
at the institutional
level, but it also
operates in creating great
groups in a very conscious kind
of way.
And we explored the whole idea--
revolution role
that DARPA played.
Class 9 last week was
really about the challenges
in the health innovation system.
It's a early stage research,
basic research focused system.
It's a quite disconnected model,
big organizational challenges
through the 27
different institutes
and centers at the National
Institutes of Health.
Getting cross-cutting science
going between those institutes
is hard.
Yet we're now at a stage where a
new revolution is coming along,
which some termed the
convergence revolution.
That's going to mandate much
more cross-cutting science,
and yet we've got an
institutional organizational
problem that's not
adapted to handling
the kind of next generation
breakthrough territories.
And now, energy.
So we're going to really bring
to bear here the legacy sector
analysis model that we've been
touching on at several points.
But today it really
comes into focus.
Obviously, we touched on it last
week in the context of the NIH,
but it really
comes to bear here.
And the issue of innovating
in complex established sectors
is a big problem for the US.
It's a problem for everybody,
it's a particular problem here.
If we can get around
and tackle this problem
we could address
a lot of issues.
Since 80% of the economy
is in these legacy sectors,
we limit our growth
rate by essentially
doing a new frontier kind of
innovation model of looking
at standing up the
next big thing,
we lose track of what
we've done in the past,
we tend to focus our innovation
on standing up new territories.
That affects our
growth rate, right?
So the whole IT sector
in the United States,
as huge as it is, is still
measured as only about 4.6%
of the US economy.
That includes copper
wire telephones
and hard bound
books, too, right?
In that information
technology sector.
It's a challenging
issue of how to bring
innovation of the sectors.
If we could figure out
a better way to do it,
if innovation is the dominant
causative factor of growth,
then we start to think
about affecting our growth
rate in a new kind of way.
So that's why this
case study, I think,
is particularly significant, not
only for energy itself, which
is obviously very important, but
for its implications of how do
we innovate in legacy sectors.
So we'll start with
Socolow and Pacala.
And who's got
Socolow and Pacala?
Matthew?
All right.
I'll just briefly
summarize their work.
As you know, both
Princeton experts,
they helped give us a
conceptual framework
for thinking about the challenge
coming up in energy technology.
And the community
have been doing
a lot of fairly sloppy
thinking about-- everybody
had their favorite silver
bullet that was going
to solve all problems, right?
And Socolow and Pacala got us
thinking that, gee, there's
not going to be a
single silver bullet,
there's going to be a
whole series of things that
need to be undertaken if we're
going to tackle the energy
technology challenge.
And so they developed
something which is now
widely known as wedges theory.
And when they were writing--
if we just stabilized
CO2 and greenhouse gases,
at the time they were writing,
that would have been enough.
We now know that we've got
to go much more deeply.
So it complicates this
wedges story significantly.
But when they were
writing, as you can see,
their assumption was
that would be the growth
curve of greenhouse
gases and we could simply
stabilize it by introducing
these wedges, that
could tackle the problem.
When they put this
out in 2004, it really
gave everyone a new
kind of picture,
a new kind of
intellectual framework
to help think about
this big energy problem.
They picked 15 different
energy initiatives,
they argued that if you
did any seven of them
you could grow them in a
reasonable time frame into--
that multi decade time frame
into large enough wedges
of energy supply that you
could bring emissions down
over a five-decade period
to a stabilized 2005.
So we now we've got an
80% reduction, not just
stabilization.
But the concept
is still with us.
Now, some of these
wedges were clearly
within the range of adoption,
and with a concerted effort
they could be scaled up
in a timely kind of way.
Others were just plain
really hard to even think
about implementing.
For example, they called
for massive deforestation.
A big challenge in countries
where that would need to occur.
They called for a 50%
reduction in driving
by 2 billion vehicles.
Yeah.
Good luck.
You know, massive adoption
of conservation tillage.
I mean, all these are
conceivable, right?
But some are harder than others.
And they take not only
changes in government
to write to policy and
technology advance,
they require very significant
behavioral challenges,
which is particularly
difficult to impose.
And others, like carbon capture
and sequestration technology,
are still, to this day, a
considerable time period away
from practical implementation.
We don't have the
right technologies yet.
And then there's a whole
period of development
and demonstration
that really needs
to be ongoing
before we can really
implement those approaches.
We just don't know what the
best practices are, particularly
in the sequestration side.
So that's some of
the challenges here.
Interestingly, Socolow
and Pacala's work
got taken up by the contending
communities battling
over climate change
at that time.
So Socolow and
Pacala, again, they're
only battling for
a 50% reduction--
I mean, excuse me, they're
battling for stabilization, not
a 50% or 80% reduction.
They argued that we
could get their wedges
without doing a lot of
breakthrough work, right?
That the solutions were at hand.
So the environmental community
was facing a big battle
with industry.
And the industry was saying,
sure, we'll do climate change,
see in 20 years we're
going to do some R&D
and we should have it done
within at least 20-year period,
no problem.
So that was obviously
unacceptable
to the environmental community.
They used Socolow and Pacala
to argue, wait a minute,
we don't need to do these
fundamental breakthroughs,
the solutions are at hand.
So in effect it
pulled both sides off
of technology
development, right?
In a period of time
where we actually really
needed to do a lot of
technology development
because I would argue
with you that if we're
going to get to the
levels of CO2 reductions
that we need to reach, there
is a lot of technology advance
that needs to go on.
And this kind of pulled
the debate out of that.
It's not their fault, that's
not what they intended at all,
but it created a kind
of positive agenda
for the environmental
committee that I
think in the end was misleading
to them as well as to others.
So that was the dilemma
in what they proposed,
but nonetheless
this wedges concept
presents a picture of how we're
going to go after this problem.
That remains
extremely important.
Matt, it's all yours.
MATT: Well, the first thing
I wanted to talk about
was Socolow and Pacala seem
to be writing to the world.
They talk about
global emissions.
And here they are publishing
in Scientific American
to popular science
readers in the US.
I think a few people
also caught on this.
Somewhere in the article they
mentioned that richer economies
tend to become less
energy-dependent because you're
not making steel or
doing these highly
energy-intensive activities.
So I think it's important to
talk about whose responsibility
is it to pick up these
wedges, and is there a way
to optimize it so that we
don't keep developing economies
from developing in the process.
AUDIENCE: Actually, I
kind of disagree at least
with the notion that the more
developed economies don't
use energy as much because--
or at least that
they don't pollute
as much, because at
least the United States,
they pollute-- what is it?
The second most in the world?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
We have like 25% of
the world's pollution,
it's just here, even though
we're extremely developed.
So I don't know if we can put a
lot of the blame on developing
countries.
It's really the pot calling
the kettle black there.
MATT: On the other
hand, I guess pollution
is something we can manage and
reduce without having that take
as much of a toll on our economy
as in developing countries
to start producing steel, right?
AUDIENCE: Well, we
haven't done that yet.
AUDIENCE: I think
that's interesting.
I think there's the potential
for more developed countries
to take a smarter approach
to how they manufacture,
but I really like that sentence.
It really shook me up
because almost it's
like it implied the wealthier
that you get as a country
the less you need to
manufacture produce.
I don't know if I'm
really misunderstanding
what that point was, but--
AUDIENCE: I think the point
that you're referencing
is on page 56 of this report.
And they talk about
how energy or how
manufacturers are increasingly
improving their energy
efficiency.
They don't necessarily say
that the impetus is no longer
on the developing world or
that richer countries have
to take on energy
reductions, but specifically
that energy efficiency
is improving,
and thus there is hope at
least in developed countries
to take up some of that,
I guess an increase
in the developing world in
manufacturing, specifically.
AUDIENCE: I think the point
that they're referencing
specifically was
a bit earlier when
they say that heavy industries
like steel and manufacturing
tend to move out of the
more developed countries
to less developed countries.
And my whole confusion
with that was
that it seems like they're
saying that that was going
to reduce emissions,
which, yes, it will reduce
the emissions in the US
and developed countries,
but it's just like moving
them to a new place.
So I was confused as to
why that is something
that they're commenting on
at all in this discussion
because it's just
moving emissions around,
it's not changing them.
To the front page 52.
Yeah.
Sorry.
That's on page 52, right?
Two long-term trends
are surely improving--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: I'm
really impressed, Steph.
That's--
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: First, as
societies get richer,
the services sector
grows in importance
relative to
energy-intensive activities
such as steel production.
So second deeply
ingrained in the pattern
of technology evolution
is the substitution
of cleverness for energy, which
is their point about energy
efficiency.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah.
And as we know from the
manufacturing case study
earlier this semester,
that turned out
to be a problematic
view, largely
from economists about
the nature and importance
of significant
production systems
in developed economies, as well
as less developed economies.
But it is a widespread
set of assumptions
that economists were
pressing at the time
that as though there
was a natural evolution
that an economy would naturally
evolve into more service sector
activities and forego the
need for a production cycle.
The problem was that that
evolution, which certainly
took place the United
States, did not necessarily
forego the need for a
strong production sector
as well, as we discussed back
in classes four and five,
because it turns out that
the production sector is
so deeply tied to your
innovation system itself.
Sorry for the recap.
MATT: Well, yeah.
I was actually on
other question--
I think Sophia asked it--
was, now that kind of
thinking about this changing,
and maybe we don't want
just services focused
by sector or industry, and
we bring back manufacturing,
does that mess up kind of
what Socolow and Pacala are
presenting here, where
that's something--
in their model,
that's something that
will help us in the long run.
AUDIENCE: Can you
say that again?
MATT: Yeah.
So Socolow and
Pacala are saying,
as countries become
more developed
than the average economy.
They kind of move towards
this service-heavy economy.
And that in the long run
helps decrease or ease
that country's carbon emissions.
But now that we've been
rethinking it and saying
manufacturing is something we
want back here in the United
States, that paradigm changes.
And how much does that
disturb the presentation
of this wedge theory.
AUDIENCE: So, actually,
I kind of a question
about how emissions
from the United States
decreased in the past 30 years?
If so, by how much?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: We actually
have been decreasing emissions,
particularly the
last seven years
in a fairly significant rate.
And, again, more analysis
needs to be done.
Martha, you probably
have insights.
AUDIENCE: Well, the only
insight they have is
because of the
natural gas boom is
one of the big
reasons we've been
reducing emissions, not because
of less consumption or--
I mean, there's some energy
efficiency, but a lot of it
has to do with gas
being cleaner than coal.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
So we've gone through
a whole technology
revolution led by fracking.
And then, another factor here
is that frankly the US has
been de-industrializing, right?
So when we reduce manufacturing
employment by 1/3,
that turns out not to have been
primarily productivity gains.
That turns out to be a real
hollowing out of that sector.
So we shut down
60,000 factories,
as we talked about in class
four, between 2000 and 2010.
So to some extent, these
are unintended consequences
of some problematic
developments in our economy.
But the big one, I think,
Martha's put us on to
is the fracking revolution.
AUDIENCE: Also, when
we do that measurement,
is it based on the emissions
per production or are results
take into account, like
how much emissions you
do by creating the products?
So I'm thinking
solar panels-- what
would be the emissions to create
solar panels and produce them?
Because that would
affect the measurement.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So I don't know
the answer to that.
I'm guessing it
doesn't include what
goes into the solar panels
or the wind turbines.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
And that's a tricky process.
What is the net emissions of
a new technology, including
its own production and
installation systems?
Making those estimates
is not simple.
How about one more
question, Matt?
MATT: All right.
Another question.
Generally, what do people think
about the seven wedges theory?
So I saw some people
had questions about it
and I did too in terms of,
yeah, some of the wedges seemed
really hard, but
some of the wedges
seem manageable on their own.
But once you start
putting all of them
together, even just from
a financial perspective,
it becomes marginally
more difficult to take
that next wedge.
And they don't actually
seem exclusive.
So if you look at
power generation,
you raise the efficiency at
1,600 large coal fired plants
from 40% to 60%,
then another one
is replaced 1,400 large
coal fired plants with gas
fired plants.
And does trying to do one wedge
cause another wedge to shrink?
And then you're looking
at adding up a lot more.
I thought it was helpful,
for a popular science
magazine I thought was
a helpful framework,
but I was wondering if
there were some shortcomings
that people had issues with.
AUDIENCE: I was a
little surprised by how
fossil fuel focused it was.
Still one of the big
solutions was carbon capture.
And like you said, one of the
options is to keep using coal,
but to just make
it more efficient.
So, I mean, I
understand the reality
that we probably will be reliant
on fossil fuels for a while,
but I thought that this
is an interesting approach
to continue in such a way.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Martha, I know you've
thought about that question.
AUDIENCE: Well, I
guess maybe only
thought I'm having is,
will the carbon capture
and storage has totally
not panned out yet
to be anything
close to economic.
So it is a little
fanciful, a piece of it.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
On the other hand, the
possibilities that a purely
renewables approach.
AUDIENCE: I see.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Is going to be doable.
You know.
I think that's
problematic as well.
AUDIENCE: Right, absolutely.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Because these are not
baseload power systems.
AUDIENCE: For me, I found
the most problematic pieces
to be kind of--
as we're commenting, it
did seem sort of arbitrary,
but in addition to just sort of
just kind of picking whatever,
the ones that they
picked, it came down to,
I don't know if I would
necessarily kind of start
if I was saying that
these are the 15 that
are going to be the most
feasible ways to get us
on these wedges.
And I'm particularly looking
at stop all deforestation.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I don't know if I
might need some more
reading in deforestation,
but that seems
to me like a variable
really interconnected kind
of big issue there.
And I feel like
there's a lot more,
and agriculture
and forestry could
have picked before
kind of blanket
with just saying stop
all deforestation.
And yeah.
So I think within each
sector there could probably
be a more meticulous approach
to kind of make them exclusive,
so you don't have this
sort of overlapping power
generation between coal fired
plants and things like that.
That was my main
issue with the wedges.
AUDIENCE: I thought it
was a very academic paper.
I think it's a really good
lens to look at the problem.
But in terms of
practicality, I don't
think it would be practical.
It seems like it's kind
of idealized, like outside
reality.
The approach I would
take with this paper
is to look at their assumptions
and then go out into the market
and talk to factories
and people who
are using these
technologies and figure out
how they think
about these things,
because they might just be like,
that's not going to happen.
So I think it's a good
lens, but I wouldn't--
I don't see it as practical.
AUDIENCE: I just looked it up.
Robert Socolow actually wrote
a follow-up article in 2011
called Wedges Reaffirmed
in Climate Central
to talk about the reception not
only from the general public,
but also from the
scientific community,
from the policy
making community.
And he seems to sort of be
of the opinion that he--
they not only overshot the
science of carbon capture,
but also really we're
trying to pander
to the quote-unquote
"general American"
and we're not as
sort of hard-hitting
with these solutions that
they could have proposed
in the magazine article.
And in particular talked
about how people commented
on the concessions
that they made
leading to benign
outcomes on fossil fuels,
as you were saying, and that
they would foster complacency.
And he says that he
doesn't understand
that fear because
when he tells someone
that we could be lucky to
figure out the technology,
then the listener completes
a sentence and says,
or we could be unlucky.
So he seems to say
that we're kind
of between a rock
and a hard place
on trying to convince people to
create a framework for energy
reduction while also
sort of maintaining
our standard of living and also
caring about the environment.
So he seems to have
gotten a lot of backlash
that he reflected
on for some time.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
Both of these folks are
very shrewd, talented people
and very perceptive.
And part of the
story here was what
we thought was the
case in 2004 and 2005,
which is just stabilization
at 2005 levels
would do it if we've got to get
a much deeper set of reductions
in the place.
AUDIENCE: I think
even when they wrote
this they suggested
that in the long term
we need to bring it down.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah.
All right they were aimed
at a 50 year period.
They recognized that
in that later period
there would really have
to be breakthroughs.
But they avoided the
breakthrough problem
in the 50 year period,
but it's now on us.
Right?
We're going to have to have
a level of technology advance
that was passed what they were--
and what policymakers in general
were thinking about that time.
That's a good closing
thought, Matt.
Anything else to add on them?
MATT: Yeah.
I think it's generally a good--
I thought it was a good
first article just that way,
but like Bush's
innovation pipeline,
there's a lot more
complexity in the test
that we need to work through.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
That's a good comparison.
Thanks, Matt.
All right.
So we're now going
to dive into--
Chuck Weiss and I affected
a whole book on this.
This is just a kind of
snapshot, but the idea
we tried to get across here is
that challenge is big enough
that we're going to have to get
inside the kind of black box
of innovation, innovation
policy, innovation proposition.
So there'd been a lot of
articles around the time we
worked on this, 2009 timetable.
And a lot of major
studies, and the studies
always said, and we're going to
need some technology advances,
let's do a lot of R&D, right?
And that's kind of
as far as they went.
And what we were attempting
to do in the book, as well
as pieces that came out of it,
like what I had you all read,
was really dig into how that
innovation system worked
and understand it in a more
coherent and real kind of way,
getting us in there to that
black box of innovation policy
and figure out
what could be done.
Just as a few background points,
historically, the government
has been much more
interventionist
in the energy sector than
most other sectors, right?
Government is historically very
interventionist in the health
sector, it's been very
interventionist in the energy
sector as well.
And the political
parties tend to have
their favorite
technologies, which
complicates the political agenda
here for a technology agenda.
It will complicate it for the
next several years for sure.
We're already seeing
some of those slides.
And then there's
another reality here,
which is we don't have a
lot of the technologies we
need at hand yet.
There's still a very significant
technology development effort
that needs to go on and a
series of these really important
strands.
We can see what
the pathways are,
but a lot of the technologies
we're going to need
are still not
technology ready, much
less being economically
ready, where
it's ready for market adoption.
So that complicates this
challenge very significant.
Energy is scale, right?
It is a gigantic sector.
And you can't
consider energy policy
unless you're considering scale.
There is a technological,
economic, political, social
paradigm that creates barriers
to change in the energy sector
that are quite significant.
Private sector R&D,
and obviously this
is private sector technology.
The government is not in
control of this technology
to say the least.
Private sector R&D is
discouraged by wild price
oscillations in energy markets.
We'll look at some of
those in just a minute.
$20 a barrel in 1998, $140 a
barrel in 2008, $35 a barrel
in 2016.
It's very hard to do R&D
against those kinds of price
disruptions.
The public sector has
been working on energy R&D
and comparatively few
technologies have transitioned.
Again, fracking frankly is the
major technology development
that really has transitioned.
And you've got to think
about parallel and supporting
policies, not only on
technology, but also on price.
Right?
So it's technology, supply,
but that's dramatically
affected by pricing.
So very large in
scale and scope.
The problem of energy,
as I said before,
really is the problem of scale.
You can think about a large
scale kind of activity,
like an Apollo type
project for pursuing this,
but you would not have an
Apollo type project that's
government contract-led, right?
We're not going to solve this
except in the private sector,
which makes the effort
considerably more complicated.
And as Socolow and
Pacala suggested to us
in the reading we
just discussed,
this is a 50 year project.
So the United States has never
done a 50 year technology
project.
We're lucky if we do three year
technology projects these days.
Apollo was a nine
year project, right?
That's about as long
as we can stand, much
less a multi-decade problem.
And then, with a
multi-decade problem,
we run the problem of
locking in prematurely
to wrong technologies.
So that's the
fundamental problem
with corn-based ethanol,
which 1970s already
felt like, great, corn-based
ethanol, what could be better?
Farmers get rich, they grow
our energy for us, how nice.
But it turned out to be not
as significant emissions
reduction, if anything,
maybe the opposite.
So locking in.
We're now every bit as addicted
to corn as we are to oil,
and locking in prematurely on
a technology is a big problem.
How do you maintain a certain
amount of technology neutrality
over a 40 year period?
We have never tried anything
as complicated as that before.
And arguably, you need to
organize around barriers
to market launch, not just
throw R&D money at the problem.
So we'll get into all of that.
But energy arguably requires
a new unified theory
of innovation because it
is such a complex project.
You can't just do
a pipeline model,
you can't just do in an
induced innovation model,
you can't just do
a manufacturing
led innovation model.
You've got to think much more
deeply about how you bring
all these models to bear using
an innovation organization
approach.
It's kind of no way of getting
out of that box in the energy
sector.
AUDIENCE: Is there
a paper that's
looking to pass
energy revolutions
and figure out like the
main kind of pushers?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Well,
we went on too many, right?
So I don't know how
many million years it
took, but we did wood fire.
We did that.
That was big.
Then, from wood we did coal.
And [INAUDIBLE] tells the story
that William Barton Rogers,
the esteemed first
president, and frankly,
genius behind the MIT
model, he died on the podium
during an MIT graduation choking
on the terms by [INAUDIBLE]
coal revolution, right?
So that was the big
revolution in that era.
We moved from wood the coal.
So that's how slow it is.
In a remarkably quick period
of time, you know 60, 70 years,
we actually moved to oil.
Right?
That was remarkably quick.
And you know we've been on
that fossil fuel revolution
ever since.
And it's not easy
to shift, so these
are very long-term projects.
And you really have
to think about time
and scale over and over again
when we think about undertaking
energy technology change.
So we talked about
some of the models
previously just to remind you
we know the pipeline model well.
For sure there is going
to be a profound need here
for breakthrough research.
There is a big valley of death
problem in that pipeline model
that we've got to
think very hard about.
But that's not the
only problem, we've
got induced innovation here.
In other words,
industry is going
they have to take responsibility
for a lot of these particularly
incremental advances.
But how do you
encourage that when
the industry is locked
into a set of technologies
that you want to mitigate?
That really complicates the
induced innovation model.
Well, it was in the article.
Chuck and I've been
thinking since then
because from the book
there's an extended pipeline
model, the whole defense
sector model where
the government engages not
just at the upfront stages,
but the later stages through
implementation as well.
What can we use in that model?
And that's a Defense
Department-owned model
by and large.
And we'll talk later when we
talk about the Dorothy Rubin
reading about whether
that's applied.
Manufacturing led.
In other words, we're
not going to have
carbon pricing for a
significant period of time.
So unless you drive
the price down,
these technologies
will never enter.
So the way you
drive price down is
through manufacturing
advances and process advances
and that becomes very
much part of what
you've got to consider in
an energy innovation model
as well.
So innovation organization.
How do you put these
complex pieces together
for a new model is really
at the core of this.
So just to summarize so far,
it's a problem of scale,
we're up against a
technological, economic,
political, social paradigm--
we'll talk about that
in a minute--
in a very complex
established legacy sector.
And maintaining
technology neutrality
over a 50 year period, a
really critical problem,
which needs a tremendous amount
of thought and organizing.
And then we've got to
undertake the integration
of the different models by
which the dynamics of innovation
get played out, right?
You can't just do pipeline
here, you can't just
do extended pipeline.
You've got to really
bring all of these
to bear because they're
all part of that solution.
So innovation organization
becomes central here
to an energy
technology revolution.
Let's look at
investments in energy.
So US federal R&D spending
on new energy technology
when we wrote this
piece was about half
of what it was in actual
dollars because it was in 1980.
So the blue is public
sector investment.
You can see the high
watermark about 1980,
and it's come down since then.
The gray line is private
sector investment levels.
You can, again, see
that that's basically
through this 2005 time
period and it hasn't
gotten much better since.
That basically fell in
half, as well, right?
So this is not the
picture you want
to have if you're going to
do a technology revolution,
all right?
Let's look at the way in
which innovating industries,
how do they spend when they're
trying to do major technology
implementations?
The semiconductor
industry invests 16%
on average of annual
revenues in R&D.
And they've got to
stay on Moore's Law.
Moore's Law may have just
ended, but that was a long term
project for them and they had to
keep investing in R&D to do it.
The pharmaceutical
sector invests 18%
because their drug
terms keep running out.
They've got to stay on
top of the R&D side.
The biotech sector invests 39%.
That may be a little
unfair comparison
because a lot of
the biotech industry
has no revenues at all, so it
may skew the numbers a bit.
But the other two are
probably pretty good signals.
Established industry.
The electronics
industry, 8% of sales.
The auto industry, at least
before the great recession,
was around 3% to
3 and 1/2 percent
of annual revenues in R&D.
Those are pretty mature sectors.
Average R&D to annual revenues
for all of US industry is 2.6%.
That includes dry
cleaners, right?
That's everybody, that's all in.
Private energy R&D as
a percentage of R&D--
R&D as a percentage of annual
revenues is less than 1%.
How are we going to do this?
And this does not--
this is not good, right?
Now, why is it so low
in the energy sector?
Well, part of the story is that
the revenues are so enormous,
right?
This is a powerful
revenue-generating sector.
So that's part of it, but
it's not a full explanation.
This is a sector that's
got an economic model
and it's sustaining
that model, and it's not
all that interested
in diversification
from what's an extremely
successful set of approaches.
Now, let's say we up
the federal R&D, right?
To kind of offset not a
terribly pretty picture
on the private sector R&D side.
When the feds really
want to do something big,
what kind of money
do they spend it on?
The Apollo program,
over nine years-- now,
this is both R&D
and implementation.
That was $185 billion in 2002
dollars over that nine year
period.
Carter-Reagan defense
buildup, right?
That got us know all the
stuff we read about in DARPA,
precision, stealth,
UAVs, submarines
that nobody likes to talk
about, a bunch of fancy stuff.
That was $445 billion
over eight years.
Doubling NIH was $138
billion over five years.
The ballistic missile
defense program,
which until fairly recently
was the largest technology
initiative the government had
going, its first six years
was $145 billion.
That's what the government
spends when it really
wants to get technology done.
It's not spending
this on energy.
OK?
We're not at those levels.
Interestingly, this is energy
in R&D spending compared
to the price of crude oil.
And you can see the remarkable
similarities in these lines,
right?
Price of oil goes up,
let's throw some R&D at it.
Price of oil goes down,
pull that R&D back, right?
You can't run an R&D program
with sustained results on kind
of a roller coaster model.
It just doesn't work.
This story is not just
true for the United States.
These are all the developed
countries, the OECD countries.
You can see a high
watermark about 1980
and similarly coming down
to less than half of that.
The black line is
the one to look at.
The International
Energy Agency--
which is the energy arm
of the OECD countries,
a highly respected
data collection,
energy analytical crew--
in 2008 they did a
major study and they
concluded that
reducing emissions
to 50% below 2005 levels.
When they added up the R&D
as well as the technology
implementation that
need to be undertaken,
they estimated that
at a $45 trillion
project over a 50 year period,
about $1.1 trillion worldwide,
$1.1 trillion per year
in R&D implementation.
So, you know, that
number may be way off.
They were guesstimating, we
got to do this much solar,
we got to do this
much wind, we have
to do this much
advanced nuclear,
we have to have this much carbon
capture and sequestration.
They were kind of adding up
what the bill might look like.
So it could be
significantly off--
but by the way, even if
it's off by a whole lot,
we're not in range.
So so far, we've been
talking about this
as though it was a problem we
could just shovel money at.
Right?
That's we've been talking about
for the last five minutes.
But everybody in
this class knows
that innovation and a
complex legacy sector,
like energy, it's much
more complicated than just
throwing money at the problem.
So you've seen
these slides before.
The US is a covered wagon
technology culture, right?
We like to leave our old
neighborhoods behind and move
new technology into
open field new frontier
kind of innovation, we take
our covered wagons west,
we go over the mountain,
we settle new technology
territories.
That's what we're pretty
good at, we like to do that.
We're not good at
this problem, right?
Bringing technology advanced
back into established sectors.
We don't do this.
And that technology, as
we've discussed before,
it has to parachute in.
And by the way, the
incumbents are going
to shoot at it on the way down.
So it's not just a matter
of throwing R&D money
at this problem.
We've got a much
bigger problem, right?
Max.
AUDIENCE: Quick question.
You said that we're not very
good at going in covered wagons
east.
Is there anyone that is?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: You know,
developing countries that
don't have mature
legacy sectors tend
to be able to innovate
in many, many areas.
So that is the story
of the stunning growth
numbers that China has built
over the last 30 years, right?
Because there wasn't
much there, so they
didn't have to overcome
these legacy sectors.
They were working in
innovating in every sector.
So they build this remarkable
10% a year growth rate.
They've now built
out a lot of it.
So their growth rate is going
to finally come down a bit
and it's starting to do so.
But that gives you a signal
of the kind of growth rate
you could have if you were able
to innovate across the board,
not just in frontier areas.
Martha.
AUDIENCE: But is it not just
because they didn't have
anything there in China,
because they're so top-down,
they could--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah.
I mean, there's organizational
issues like that too.
But you can look at Korea,
you're looking at Taiwan,
and you can look at the IT
economy in India, right?
Another staggering success story
of stunning rates of advance.
The government had
kind of fenced off
most of hard industries into a
fairly socialist kind of system
and pretty inefficient.
They haven't fenced
off the IT sector
and that was not a
heavy governmental hand,
that was just take off, right?
And it's a remarkable story.
So it's not always the
way-- you don't always
need that governmentally hand,
but it's an important point.
So the US just doesn't
do this very well.
The example on the
slide is, we don't
go back and fix the health
care delivery system.
We've been fighting over
that for about 15 years.
We're pretty good at
doing biotech, right?
That worked.
But taking on a whole
health care delivery system
has proved elusive
to say the least.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah,
hospitals and the whole service
side of health care.
And there's technology
tied to that across, too.
So a complex established sector
is not a level playing field,
right?
One of the advantages
of technology
stand up in a frontier
is there's no incumbent,
you just do it.
Right?
That's the India story, right?
That's the story of the
IT revolution in the US.
There wasn't anything
really quite like computing
before computing, it just--
there was nobody in the way.
Similarly, biotech didn't
really have anybody in the way,
whereas these health care
delivery or energy problems are
much more complicated because
you're up against established
incumbents.
And these incumbents have strong
technology models and systems
often with vast
infrastructure, right?
Think about gas stations
and gas pipeline systems.
They have an economic model and
they've driven down the cost
curve, so it's a
remarkably efficient system
with remarkably low
energy prices in the US.
There's a massive political
support system, right?
These are strong regional
employers and important parts
of local and regional
economies, they
are very strong politically.
And there's a whole
social support system.
For many decades, chemical
engineering departments
were essentially at every
unit major university,
were essentially part of
the fossil fuel system.
That's obviously
changed, but there
was a whole set of
academic social support
systems that are there.
And, look, the US public
has an expectation
that we get cheap energy prices.
Right?
Try taking that one
on, politically, right?
That's one of the political
problems with trying
to impose a carbon tax.
What a wonderful message--
hey, all your energy prices
are going to go up, you know?
It's not a terribly
attractive political message.
And part of the problem
here is that the new energy
technologies have got to be
price competitive the moment
they arrive in the marketplace.
So we'll get to that
problem in a minute.
A carbon charge was going
to be a way to adjust this.
In other words, it would bring
the fossil fuel prices up,
and therefore, the
new technologies
didn't have to drive down nearly
as much down the cost curve.
It would be easy
to introduce them.
They, in effect, have a
significant incentive.
We're not going to
do that, at least
for a significant
period of time.
So what do we do?
Some things we've
talked about already,
we've got to have a
large program that's
sizable in scope.
In the US, it's going to
have to be private-sector
led because that's where all the
technology and infrastructure
is.
Government doesn't control
it except in certain ways.
That means a public-private
partnership kind of model
is going to be needed.
You've got this problem
of technology neutrality
and avoiding technology lock-in.
And, again, we're
going to have to think
about organizing this one we're
getting into now around launch
pathways.
So we came up with a kind of
a four-step way of looking
at launching technologies.
So there's lots of
literature on R&D
and you've read now a fair
amount of it by the time
we reach class 10 here.
But there's very little
literature on market launch.
It just is not a topic
that has been taken up
by the science and
technology policy literature.
So the essentially idea was,
think about launch pathways.
Different technologies going
to launch in different ways.
Launching batteries into
an automotive sector
is a really different project
than launching biofuels
into the transport sector.
But figure out the
launch pathways
and figure out for
some common launch
pathways that certain
kinds of technologies have,
and we'll get to
that in a second.
Then, step two is tie those
launch pathways to whatever
means of policy support you can
put to those launch pathways,
right?
Do a gap analysis in
the innovation system,
both front end and
back end, and then
work on filling in the gaps
in that innovation system.
So a four-step process.
We'll take these
apart for a minute.
The US has never tried to do
anything this tough, right?
I think there have been
technology challenges
themselves that are
harder than this, right?
Because we can kind
of see the strands
that we're going to get over
the next 25 or 30 years.
They're kind of out there.
We kind of know what
solar is going to be like,
we kind of know what
wind is going to be like,
we can see what's
going to happen
in storage to some extent.
We kind of know what the
paths are going to be.
And these are not--
this is not like the Manhattan
Project, that was a tougher
technology project.
But this is such a tough
implementation task,
we have never ever tried to do
anything this complex before.
So it's a challenge
worthy of your careers.
It is the big one.
Martin?
AUDIENCE: So your
focus is policy,
Weis's is government because
you both wrote a book together,
right?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah.
Chuck was-- he and I
taught at Georgetown
and he was chairman
of the department,
so he was the one who kicked me
into teaching some years back.
And then, we just got to
know each other, decided
let's take this book on
because we saw that the science
and technology policy world,
it just not really thought
about the details of the
technology policy for energy.
Obviously, this one,
a lot of literature.
AUDIENCE: Because I was thinking
it would be interesting if you
talked to like a Sloan
strategy professor,
like a [INAUDIBLE] strategy
because they would have some
insights into--
because it's not
intuitive, usually,
like a business component
strategy, especially
for complex sectors,
but it definitely
is a way of doing it.
Usually you focus
on very niche market
that you know no one would try
to fight you at the beginning
and then you grow and you grow.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
And we're going to get
into exactly that point,
too, Martin, that's a very
key step in our strategy
for a lot of these technologies.
AUDIENCE: And another
thing-- another reason too
is because it's not simple.
Since it's complex, you'll
need different business models
for different kinds
of products, so I
feel like they can
make a matrix that
might be really
useful, especially
like MIT Energy Initiative,
because I'll be like,
oh, if you have this
kind of strategy,
this is a task-- this is how
I would go about growing it.
And with MIT especially,
you have mentors
that are going to be there.
There are some connections--
it'd be really interesting.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
And look-- a lot of
this thinking I did
was because I got pulled
into the MIT Energy
Initiative in
various ways, and had
to think with the
faculty teams that
are developing these
amazing reports that MITI
did over the years.
I had to understand
those reports
because I had to help
those communities bring
their reports to
the policy world,
so I had to read
in pretty deeply--
so a lot of what I'm stumbling
onto in the article you read,
but also the book that is
a larger statement of it
really comes out of
my MIT experience.
And of course Sloan
was pretty deeply
involved in each one of
those, which was part
of what made them powerful.
But Martin, when I
do the next edition,
I'm going to get you to
do the business side.
So let's go back
to step one we'll
do a little more detail here so
you get what I'm talking about.
Let's categorize the
launch categories, right?
So we know we've got to
do a bunch of wedges--
different technologies
often embedded
in each different wedge.
How do we look at
launch pathways
as a way of looking at
the different launch
pathways in energy, and
seeing if some are similar,
then you could aggregate
the policy support
mechanisms around those.
So some technologies
are experimental,
and are just going to
require long term research.
So Max, that's
your paper, right?
Fusion is still long
term, incredible potential
if we could get there.
We're not really
ready for much more
beyond R&D and some
demonstration commitments
at this stage.
So that's a federal R&D role--
hydrogen fuel cells, a
similar kind of problem.
So that's experimental
technologies--
that's one category.
Just do R&D for those folks.
The second category would
be potentially disruptive
innovations that could be
launched in-- you guessed it,
Martin--
niche markets, right?
So that's typically
how induced innovation
works in the private sector.
A private sector company will
identify market opportunities--
typically a niche market--
take that market, move into
it, and start to scale up
a new technology advance.
That's the LED story--
remarkable success story.
They found niche
markets that couldn't
be dealt with by either
of their incandescent
or fluorescent
technology competitors.
They found niche markets
where LEDs were--
a so much better answer
than the competitors,
and then they scaled
into those niche markets,
and they used that
opportunity to drive the price
down so that, when
the time came,
they could actually compete
over that extended time
period of driving the
cost down to compete
with the other sectors.
So that's a classic example of
launching into a niche market.
Solar PV has had some of
that opportunity as well--
that's been launched into
a bunch of niche markets.
But then, there's a more
complicated category,
and these are--
we'll call them
secondary innovations,
or component
innovations, and this
is a lot of what energy is.
Secondary innovations
are components
in larger systems that face
immediate price competition
based on price, but they can
launch in an uncontested way
if the owner of that larger
system wants them, right?
If that technology is acceptable
to that system owner, operator,
then they can be accepted.
So all they have to do
is drive price down,
and then they can
come in, right?
So batteries for
plug-in hybrids--
that's a great
example here, right?
The auto sector-- they've been
burned so many times by fossil
fuel prices that's
complete wrecked them--
we're on time number three now--
that they're happy to have a
much larger share of hybrids,
or indeed electrics, in
their auto portfolio.
So this would not be a
contested launch-- they're
willing to take this stuff.
But you've got to
get the price down,
which we still haven't been
able to achieve yet from really
widespread introduction.
But that would be an example
of a secondary innovation
with an uncontested launch.
The hard stuff is
secondary innovations
with a contested launch.
That's carbon capture
and sequestration.
So the message to a utility
company in that situation is--
hi, we want you to do carbon
capture and sequestration.
This is going to reduce the
efficiency of your plant by 40%
and add 50% to your costs, or
numbers somewhat like those.
Is that ballpark
numbers, Martha?
Is that in range?
MARTHA: And there's no upside--
I mean there's no financial--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah,
what's the benefit here?
And finance it too--
you finance it, right?
And nail your utility
customers, right?
Good luck.
Right?
That's what you call
a contested launch.
The only way these people
are going to do this
is if you tell them--
they're going to
violate criminal laws
unless they do it.
I mean, that's about
all you can do here.
You have to regulate
these, right?
There's no other move.
I mean, there are some
other categories here, too,
that we need conservation and
end-use efficiency always needs
work, and advances
in manufacturing--
technologies for scale up.
Those are important
as well, but these
are the four major territories,
the four major launch pathways,
we have.
And then we've got a whole set
of policy packages, all right?
So for front end support, right?
We do R&D, and--
it would be great to
grow some of that R&D.
That will help us with
experimental, that'll
help us in all four
categories, because all
these technologies need work.
Back end incentives, to
encourage the technology
deployment, right?
That's really needed for
secondary or component
technologies, particularly
when they've gotten--
the need for both
contested and uncontested.
But you could really use
these incentives to encourage,
and we've done it, lower
prices of automobiles
that happen to be hybrids
or electrics, right?
So we've done those.
You can see what I'm
talking about here--
tax credits, loan
guarantees, price guarantees,
government procurement programs,
new product buy-down programs--
we've tried a whole
series of these.
And Congress just renewed
a lot of the tax incentives
that have been so
important to wind and solar
for a multi-year
period last year,
so those are going to
remain in place for a while.
But front end, R&D support.
Back-end incentives,
carrots-- typically
for uncontested launch.
Niche-- remember, the industry,
if it can find a market niche,
you don't have to do this stuff.
They're going to need help on
the front end R&D probably,
but if you can launch into
a market niche-- that's
why it's so attractive to try
and find a market niche where
we can launch these
technologies, right?
Because that's a way of
starting to scale up,
and then buying yourself time
to drive down the price curve.
The hard one is sticks, right?
So for secondary technologies
where you're going to have
a contested launch-- the
industry sector doesn't want
it--
you're going to have to
use regulatory requirements
and mandates to require
this to occur, right?
And-- a carbon tax
is a form of this.
It's organized around-- creating
a new kind of financial reality
for these kinds of firms.
So pick your energy
technology, see
if you can group it
into a launch category,
and then step two-- tie
your incentive package
to those launch pathways.
Follow me so far?
OK.
Step three-- you're
familiar with this by now--
look at the gaps in
the innovation system,
and you've got to look at
the gaps on the front end,
and you got to look at
the gaps in the back end
of the innovation system.
And then step four--
duh.
Fill the gaps, right?
In that innovation pipeline.
And that moves from every stage,
from research and development,
all the way through
prototype and demonstration,
and testing, and deployment,
into a commercial market--
you've got to look at all
of those stages, right?
And the production phase
too, as we've talked about.
We've talked about identifying
the gaps in the innovation
system--
I'm going to skip this--
some mechanisms that we'll talk
about in this class for filling
some of those gaps.
ARPA-E, arguably-- and we'll
talk about this in a bit--
filled a gap in the
US energy R&D system
for breakthrough
technology advances.
Maybe we need a better
government mechanism
for large scale
testing and deployment.
There's a sore need in carbon
capture and sequestration,
and we lack a
government corporation
that can conduct this kind
of demonstration level.
That's part of the
reason why we just
haven't been able to get there
in terms of demonstration
of that technology.
Those are some gap standards--
test beds are part of the gaps.
In energy, there is this big
problem of new functionality.
That's a technology problem you
need to understand in energy.
IT created new functionality
from the outset.
So you've heard me
tell this story before.
I was happy to spend a
ridiculous amount of money
on my Apple 2E because it
did all kinds of stuff for me
that I couldn't
do before, right?
That would be new functionality.
Spreadsheets, all kinds
of stuff like that, right?
Energy technologies--
first generation,
by and large, don't give
you new functionality.
The nice thing about
new functionality
is that people are willing
to pay a premium if they
can do something entirely new.
But I don't know
whether my laptop
is plugged into coal or nuclear
power, or hydro, or the sun--
I have no idea, right?
There's no product
differentiation for me
in the way in which
I get electricity.
Now some utilities--
Connecticut is an
interesting example--
are attempting to
create that background
knowledge for consumers, so they
can actually pick technologies
they're interested
in, but that's
not a widespread model yet.
So there's not much new
functionality in electricity--
they're all still electrons.
It's tough to do
product differentiation.
Cars, right?
There is a difference
between a Tesla and--
the thing I drive, right?
Because if you happen to be into
rapid torque and acceleration,
Tesla does provide you
similar functionality--
but that's about it.
In most driving
circumstances, it's just not
all that different,
and a hybrid certainly
is not all that different.
Tesla brilliantly
figured out, as did
Prius, brand differentiation
in their market launch.
They figured out how to
create a really cool vehicle,
and you could sell it on
your image of yourself
as being cool for
buying a Tesla, right?
It worked very
well in California,
and still does does, right?
And Prius did something
similar, right?
You're not just
driving a car-- you're
bragging about your
environmental outlook
on the world, right?
So this is a way of
getting around the fact
that there isn't that much
product differentiation,
there's not that
much functionality
in the energy sector.
I think there will be.
I'd like to--
LEDs are quite neat,
and you can have
a light wall, or a light floor.
And I'd pay for that--
that would be cool, as opposed
to a light bulb hanging
overhead.
That's new functionality,
so I'd pay for that.
But that's not first generation
of energy technologies--
that's not happening yet.
It's harder to create product
differentiation and new
functionality in the
first generation of energy
technologies, which
underscores how complicated
the market launch is.
AUDIENCE: There are
some technologies
that can offer new
functionality, if not
for the consumer, then
for the people are paying
for it-- like the utility.
One example would be--
fusion produces
lots of neutrons,
and you could use that to
get rid of nuclear waste--
could be nice, and there's
virtually nothing else
that could do that.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
So yes, that may be the silver
bullet-- we're just still
a while away from it.
AUDIENCE: Nuclear waste is like,
a trillion dollar market, so
[INAUDIBLE].
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
And the problem for
the utility companies
is, to adopt new technologies
they-- generally speaking--
have to pay more, right?
Although we're working on
driving those costs down.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: We
made a lot of progress.
AUDIENCE: What I'd look into
[INAUDIBLE] like a process,
it's a whole supply chain
for energy, so lines,
where you produce it, when it
gets over, and what dissipates.
So figuring out how
the supply chain
is flawed to create products
that fix the supply chain,
so it's a lot better, and they
don't have those [INAUDIBLE]
by the way.
That's the product, right?
This system is broken, I fix
the system with this product,
and so because energy
is going to come out
either way the same way, right?
That's how I think about it.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Right, and you
can think about smart grid
options that do create
new functionalities as well
AUDIENCE: Or mobile
energy sources
that can be near cities,
because then you don't have
to transport them long ways.
And-- especially for
disrupting big companies,
they spend so much money
on putting the lines,
and they have to
pay for regulations,
and it slows them down.
So a new mover can do something
like that, and disrupt them.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
Finding those market
niches is a task
that is now upon us,
because we're not
going to do a carbon tax.
So let me just
recap for a minute.
You have to apply all
the innovation models--
pipeline, induced,
extended, manufacturing led,
innovation, organization.
You've got to think about
this, and [INAUDIBLE]
by looking at all the
dynamics of innovation
and how to organize them.
And we need the four step
process here-- figure out
the launch categories, group
them with similar technologies,
apply the right incentive
package to that category.
Look at the gaps in
the innovation system,
and work on filling those gaps.
So that's the four-step
process we've got so far.
That's enough.
Why don't we do some Q&A here?
Sorry for that extended
wrap, but you basically
now know everything I know.
Who's got this one?
MATT: I have.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: All
right, Matt, all yours.
MATT: Yeah.
I think you managed to be
more thorough than the reading
example.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
That's because there
was a book behind
it, but I didn't
want to make you buy two of
my books-- one is enough.
MATT: I guess my main innovation
was very similar to Max's.
I think all of the other
readings for this week--
look at things that
the US is trying,
but I think it would be
really interesting to talk
about learning opportunities.
You mentioned China, and it
still seems like that's-- maybe
to me at least--
not going back east as
much as going into--
AUDIENCE: The centralization?
MATT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MATT: Sure, yeah.
And just not making the
same mistakes that we made,
setting up first.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Well, they are
standing up two
thousand-megawatt coal-fired
power plants a week still.
MATT: So are there true examples
of really innovating, where you
already have a legacy sector.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
You know, when
we read that reading on DARPA
a couple of classes ago,
as we talked about at the
time, the defense sector--
it's a legacy sector, right?
It's very locked into
its technologies,
into its social organization,
into its economic and budgeting
models.
It's very hard to
innovate there--
you're up against a lot of
established systems there.
Yet DOD has been able to
bring on a whole set of very
interesting advanced
technologies over the last 25
or 30 years.
So it does tell you that this
is not Mission Impossible,
and there are
organizational lessons--
as you've read in the textbook--
that we can pull out of DOD.
Part of it has to do
with some of the rules
that we've talked
about previously.
Part of it has to
do with finding
a community of change agents,
and that's very, very critical.
So you need to develop
the new technologies.
You use an island
bridge model to attempt
to get the decision
maker community
to force your approach
on the overall system.
And then to do that
is going to require
a community of change agents.
And there are communities
of change agents
that we're starting
to see in energy.
I do think that we are entering
into a very significant energy
innovation wave,
and we can already
start to see some
of the outlines.
We've seen a fracking
revolution in the United States
that has completely changed
the landscape of US energy
dependency, and
it's very dramatic.
I mean, the entire energy supply
system of the United States
has been turned upside down--
something which nobody ever
thought was conceivable, right?
And that is a set of
technology advances
that were originally pushed
by several of the energy
laboratories, developed
that core technologies
behind fracking,
and proceeded to--
it was implemented over about
a 15-year period as something
by a wildcat maverick community
in the natural gas sector that
took these technologies up and
worked on implementing them,
and it really changed things.
And the United States leads
that technology revolution,
so we have 100,000-- now
there's a lot of debate
about a lot of these operations,
the environmental consequences
of them.
We have about 100,000, roughly,
net fracking operations
ongoing now in
the United States.
The country closest to us is
China-- it has about 6,000,
all right?
So we have a big lead on that
energy technology revolution.
We have-- we can see--
solar and wind
now, which are now
scaling up to trillion-dollar
worldwide energy sectors.
They're going to be
very, very big, right?
So this revolution is
now starting, right?
The real question for
the US-- and we'll
talk about this more
later-- is whether it's
going to play, right?
Whether it's going
to ride this wave.
MATT: Yeah, it definitely seems
like a theme of the class.
DARPA worked-- let's
try ARPA-E for energy,
or a DARPA-like
funding model for NIH.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: But it's
a more complicated process
than just having a DARPA.
DARPA can be a change
agent, but you've
got to get these
steps down too, right?
MATT: Right.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: When you
work on the implementation
side.
AUDIENCE: Actually,
regarding the ARPA-E.
I notice that DARPA has a
budget of funds like $5 billion?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Three.
AUDIENCE: OK, $3 billion--
whereas ARPA-E has a budget
of--
maybe $100 million?
Couple hundred million?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
$300 million.
306, Martin, right?
AUDIENCE: How is
it we can expect
that ARPA-E is going
to do what DARPA did
if it has a tenth the budget?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So I want
to save exactly that question
for our ARPA-E piece.
Is that OK?
Would you forgive me,
but bring it back?
AUDIENCE: That's fine.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: All right.
How about it?
What else we got, Matt?
MATT: I don't know if
you want to go here,
but you did mention and
allude to this earlier, that--
beyond energy like
this is a framework
that can be used for
any legacy sector.
I think a lot of our papers
are applying the framework.
It's interesting to see if
there were any insights into how
it becomes specific to whatever
industry wants [INAUDIBLE]..
I don't know if you wanted
to move away from energy.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: It's
a very good question,
and the purpose of our
textbook was really
to take lessons that
we've thought about
in energy with the
realization-- oh, we
knew energy was a legacy
sector, and we realized--
oh, wait a minute.
Most of the economy
is a legacy sector.
Oh, we came up with this
four step process energy.
Maybe we could think about
that four step process
for a lot of other stuff, too.
That was frankly-- a little
more sophisticated than that,
but that was the essence of our
conceptual realization process.
So-- I do think that
these steps here
are steps that you've got
to think through when you're
innovating in a legacy sector.
You've got to think about the
different innovation models
you've got, and how to
organize those in new ways,
because all of them are going
to be required in the legacy
sector-- but you also
have to think about,
what are your launch categories?
What are the barriers to launch?
How are you going to
overcome those barriers?
What's the right incentive
package and support system?
Can you do niche launch, which
gets you out of this whole box?
What are the gaps in
your information system?
I think you've got to
go through all of those
when you think about legacy
sector innovation in general,
and we did a little of that
in the health care discussion
last week.
AUDIENCE: When I
was looking at this,
I was thinking a lot about edge
cases in computer science--
like, what if I got the
best product, right?
And then tried to go
through the framework,
and see how I would pan it out.
So say like fusion, right?
How would it work out, and
how is the system structured
to help bring innovation?
So-- in ideal innovation,
how would it work,
and how would the dynamics be?
And then also, a horrible
innovation, right?
It's really not even innovation.
I think Tesla got caught on
this, that they were doing
the same battery technology that
ARPA-E [INAUDIBLE] figured out,
and they're trying to
get government incentives
and go through.
And so-- that way,
you can figure out--
this is really not
innovating, but they're
trying to use these resources.
So I think that was a
really interesting thing
to maybe try to
do in the future--
different types of-- because
there's all the categories
of energy technologies.
What if you try to figure
out the ideal solution,
and try to push it
through the framework?
How would they be
able to function?
Because that way,
you can also find
organizational gaps, like the
politics would not allow it,
or other things.
I thought it was interesting.